we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
caller who says I should stop catering
to stupid people take a listen
hey David I've noticed that a lot of the
time now you preface your talking points
with well just so you know I'm gonna say
something george w bush said and was
reasonable right neil cavuto said that
was reasonable but just remember that
doesn't mean i like neil cavuto remember
george w bush is a war criminal except
okay who cares if people can't separate
a person overall they're like what a
person is overall from them making a
point that's fair or reasonable from
time to time if everything is guilt by
association with these people who cares
what they think
don't even practice these things anymore
it's just dude these people are stupid
what do you guys think so what the
caller is referring to is for example
recently george w bush put out a totally
bland uncontroversial call for unity
around coronavirus and it you know
donald trump flipped out attacked him
and i said guys you know when when
george w bush sounds reasonable given
how terrible of a president he was you
know that things have gotten really
wacky and people started tweeting me
David here normalizing you're
rehabilitating the reputation of war
criminal george w bush and i clarified a
bunch of times that's that's not what
i'm doing
my views on george w bush haven't
changed he just despite being so bad he
made sense this one time should I just
stop the disclaimers I want to hear from
you let me know what you think we've got
a great bonus show for you today barbers
are cutting people's hair on the
Michigan Capitol lawn to protest the
coronavirus shutdowns we will talk about
yet another company touted by Trump
getting a very very fancy billion dollar
border wall construction contract
probably won't surprise some of you and
Michael Cohen Trump's former personal
attorney is going to be released from
prison all of those stories and more on
the bonus show and remember Monday
Memorial Day one-day membership special
huge men
discount you want to take advantage on
Monday get on my newsletter at david
pakman.com